dancer Harry Potter just got a new
installment of the series from author JK
Rowling but not everyone is happy the
stories tell the history of magic in
North America but Native American fans
have pointed out that they actually
appropriate cultural elements and paint
native people as fantasy creatures the
best thing about the whole Harry Potter
universe was that we could easily fit
into the space and we could put on robes
we could grab a wand and there you have
it your native wizard and now with this
new rendition of native Wizards and
indigenous magic you know it's really
harmful and it kind of azad Assizes us
but Wellings portrayals of Native
Americans aren't unique they're part of
a long history of Native
misrepresentation in media
representations of indigenous people in
film usually fall under three categories
the noble savage the Indian princess and
the native warrior and they tend to be
depicted as historical figures rather
than modern-day people people have a
very skewed perspective applae are they
think that we're primitive people that
we were savage people and that you know
we are not modern people now they think
of us as the drunk Indians as being
uneducated but we're lawyers or doctors
were teachers were musicians when
indigenous people are portrayed in a
contemporary setting the result isn't
always that nuanced either so you knew
you were coming here he was told
we told him oh gosh are there spirits
and then of course there's a question of
who gets to play Native characters in
film Hollywood is often used non-native
actors to portray native characters
meaning we get a case of the red face
the pan is our tribes bravest warrior
but maybe things are changing the film
the revenant not only used indigenous
tropes images characters but it also
took the time to include indigenous
perspectives and input the research that
they did and even when you look at the
costuming that they did that is very
authentic and that is very important and
it is absolutely progress in the way
that we are representing it as native
people and it's worth noting how a film
that authentically portrays indigenous
characters beliefs and life did a lot
better than these films so when is the
rest of the media industry going to get
the message that it's time to move on
from the tantos Tiger Lillies and
Pocahontas